Guten Morgen Tim.
Du meinst wir können es einfach LMP demnächst einfach bei der NSA direkt Husten.
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 295 vom 13 April 2019 ausnahmsweise mal direkt aus der Metaebene mal wieder ja.
Hat er gesehen dass das auch sonst nicht so gut.
Tonspuren verkackt doppelt vergeben das ist hier der Winder.
Der brexit ist auch noch kaputt.
Brexit habe ich auch noch kaputt gemacht der fällig die nächste Wette also.
Gut das gut dass der Tim zurück ist und Jana ich hole Scheck ist aufgefallen dass wir bei der letzten Sendung Markus und ich einen Titel zum zweiten Mal vergeben haben.
Messdiener dürfte jetzt darüber abstimmen wie die sendung stattdessen heißen soll.
In den Kommentaren zur nicht zu dieser Sendung sondern zur anderen da wo der die die die das Dubel hat mit der LMP2 122.
Innerhalb dass er sicherlich aufmerksam gehört und irgend irgendein klugen Satz verzeihe gegeben haben der nicht schon irgendein Sendungstitel gewesen ist Hauswirt auch in zunehmendem Maße schwieriger ne.
Meins uns gehen die klugen Sätze aus.
Das natürlich auf keinen Fall aber vielleicht,
wiederholt man sich ja dann auch irgendwie innerhalb von 78 Jahren mal also,
wir blicken ja gleich auch noch mal ein bisschen weiter zurück bei unser Hauptthema heute und haben im Vorfeld schon festgestellt und man so lange ist das alles schon her da sind schon,
Menschen wieder zu Erwachsenen herangewachsen und all diese Dinge das bedenkt man gar nicht wann.
Die ich habe noch eine noch eine noch ein Logbuch auf Halde wie man so schön sagt,
das werden wir zeitnah dann auch veröffentlichen das wird dann die LMP 296.
Guck dir selber Russians.
Ja das ist immer für mich ist das total überraschend weil die hat ja gestern schon aufgenommen mit Frank Rieger und zwar haben wir uns in einer,
da wir uns geht nur mit mit IP Sicherheits Gesetzgebung in Deutschland auseinandergesetzt spezifisch so ein bisschen reflektiert aus Perspektive des Chaos Computer Clubs und.
Der
den verschiedenen Einmischung des Chaos Computer Clubs auch da ist uns aufgefallen dass wir Wölfe sind wenn du so zurückblickt auf die Staatstrojaner Urteile und so der Farbe haben wir noch nicht mal mehr in in voller Breite ausgerollt aber es,
das AT Sicherheitsgesetz 2.0 rollt ja auf uns zu und deswegen haben Frank und ich den meine komplette Sendung gewidmet frank war auch am Montag noch mal im Bundestag dazu und,
das Thema ist heiß und deswegen haben wir es vergeben.
Dann aber noch vor einiger Zeit schon eine LMP 300 angekündigt und dann wieder erschrocken festgestellt hoch das alles gar nicht so einfach wenn wenn ein Tim in,
wo ist die noch mal immer Ecuador rei ne Spanien.
Wenn ein Team in Spanien sitzt aber es war.
Mich einfach raus aus der Botschaft.
Also läuft und der Vorverkauf wird in dieser Woche starten. Bitte auf den Twitter wann genau.
Genau sagen vielleicht auch noch mal am Kanal Bescheid aber geht dann bald los.
Genau Feedback Herbert feedback.de
als Wahlhelfer bei der Europawahl 2019 möchte ich euch bitten keine ungültigen Stimmzettel zugeben diese werden sehr wahrscheinlich eh nur von uns Wahlhelfern und das in
in der Region 7 Pro Wahllokal gesehen und gelesen,
mir zumindest ist von Amts wegen wie auch privat egal was der Einzelne wählt ich schüttele höchstens den Kopf am Ende der Auszählung ungültige kreativ gestellt
gestaltete Wahlzettel können zwar belustigend sein erschweren aber die Arbeit von uns Wahlhelfern ungemein denn wir müssen über jeden ungültigen Zettel im Wahlvorstand einen Beschluss fassen
und den damit verbundenen Papierkram erledigen und die Kommentare auf diesen stünzel werden nicht im Protokoll erfasst nach Ostsee
Zeitzählung Wandel wandern alle Stimmzettel in ein Archiv bis zur nächsten Wahl an den Ergebnissen ändern ungültige Wahlzettel nicht sie gelten als Enthaltung bzw nicht abgegebenen Stimmen und werden am Ende rechnerisch,
Ideen gewinnenden Parteien zugeschlagen also.
Das geht allerdings nicht für afd-wähler afd-wähler müssen ganz groß von links nach rechts links unten nach rechts oben AFD drauf.
Und merkel muss weg und habe ich jetzt auch häufig Schnuller Schnuller,
ich habe mir Markus Lanz angeschaut da war der Kevin Kühnert und so ein Pfosten von der AFD der wie ich all seiner Mundart Namen nicht weit von da wegkommen wo ich wech komm essen,
der diesen Essener AFD und was hat der für eine Scheiße gelabert da stellt der sich hin.
Klimawandel gibt es nicht.
Klimawandel gibt sich die wir sehen das nur ein bisschen kritischer vietnet ganz gerne mal wissenschaftlich bewiesen und wen sie so,
Himmel wenn du wüsstest was Wissenschaft ist dann wüsstest du auch dass das links Twist ich habe und dann dann haben sie da noch ein bisschen weiter drüber diskutiert und dann sagt dann haben sie gesagt ja es wird wärmer ne Aufzeichnung und so weiter und sagt ja aber nicht in Deutschland,
dann musst du den Herr Kevin Kühnert darauf hinweisen dass der Klimaanlage an Landes und Bundes Grenzen keine,
ich sehe die als nächstes sitzt die AFD und Anna Grenze und will das Klima nicht reinlassen ja okay also lassen wir das also für den bitte von links oben nach rechts oben Klima,
Kreta Stadt Kreta oder was auch immer schreibt irgendwie.
Götzis Wetter nur für deutsche.
Unglaublich ey der wird sich demnächst noch immer also nach dem Wirtschaftsflüchtling kommen die Klimaflüchtlinge weiße oje.
Die haben auch schon.
Also für alle also alle afd-wähler bitte möglichst schöne bunte Bilder zeigt dass ihr euch nicht in in diese
einfachen Kategorien pressen lass die der Wahlzettel euch vorgibt schreibt der Mann Gedicht oder auch mal ne fordert mal was schreibt er mal eine konkrete Forderungen drauf,
na man kann auch also danke da ist eurer Kreativität sind keine Grenzen gesetzt.
Ist vom Pferd mit der eigentlichen Intention des Feedbacks kannst du den klinkerarbeiten ja sorry.
Ja okay Herbert ja Herbert danke für die Anregung.
Ihre Nummer komplett auf Toilette gehen.
Und dann habe ich noch eine E-Mail bekommen von Mike Michalke,
Hi der von der Kathrin Collection Society im ZDF und übrigen an der Heinrich-Heine-Universität in,
Düsseldorf angestellt oder tätig ist denn er hat einen schönen beispielrechner für Sensitivität und Spezifität ins Netz gestellt und es wirklich ganz schön den haben wir dann mal verlinkt weil man dort,
gerade diese Werte mit welchem mit Sensitivität und Spezifität einstellen kann und dann sagt er ein auf
100.000 Entscheidungen wie viele Fehler Entscheidungen zu der Stadt finde kommen natürlich sehr interessante sehr interessante Werte raus wenn du da jetzt irgendwie so Beispiel Thema Schwangerschaftstest oder Filterung von Online-Inhalten geprüfte Inhalte 100000
und dann unter der Annahme,
das ist nämlich die die entscheidende Frage wie hoch ist der tatsächlich illegale Anteil der Spieler dann auch noch mal für deine Sensitivität und Spezifität eine Rolle,
weil du ja quasi.
Wie wie erkenne ich das jetzt einfach also wenn tatsächlich nur ein Prozent der Inhalte illegal sind du aber bei einem.
Nicht illegalen Inhalte mit einer Wahrscheinlichkeit von 0,5 % trotzdem sagt er ist illegal die,
nicht illegalen aber 98% deiner Fehler ausmachen dann hast du am Ende dich trotzdem mehr viel Entscheidungen,
als tatsächlicher Entscheidung das ist sehr schön dort dargestellt das ist so hier das ist alles wie wie nennt man das.
Nicht responsive aber eben in die interaktif zumindest ne der schieben sich dann Farben hin und her der Tim ist schon ganz begeistert,
das Öl kann man sich mal anschauen das zeigt das sehr gut Einfluß diagnostische Güte auf die Qualität der Ergebnisse mit Beispielrechnung und Erläuterungen so macht man das vielen Dank für diese Empfehlung.
Dann haben wir noch ein kleines kleinen follow-up zur letzten Sendung wo wir über die.
Ermittlungen gegen das Zentrum für politische Schönheit gesprochen haben da hat sich dann der,
der Justizminister mit den Ermittlern getroffen und sie haben sich dann einigkeit herrscht Uneinigkeit darüber dass es keinen hinreichenden Tatverdacht für die Bildung einer kriminellen Vereinigung gibt entsprechend wurde,
und diese Ermittlung dann auch zügig eingestellt interessant ist was dann noch zu dem,
der heißt wirklich laugna ich habe gerade extra nicht den Namen gesagt weil ich dachte der hat doch bestimmt lahninger.
Nee Lauinger.
Lauinger Dieter Lauinger ist der Justizminister in.
Thüringen interessant ist aber eher dieser Staatsanwalt Martin zschächner sdz schr chnar das ist auch ein richtig schöner deutscher Name,
chechener.
Über den wurde dann auch mal so ein bisschen heraus geguckt was hat der denn so für Entscheidungen getroffen und so ne z.b. gab es ein Verfahren gegen einen
Mitarbeiter des afd-bundestagsabgeordneten Stephan Brandner.
Dieser Mitarbeiter hatte die Aussage getätigt afros seien nicht wie wir sondern nur Menschen die in die Zivilisation hinein gezwungen worden wurden,
so der da hat es dann einer das wurde angezeigt ja natürlich wegen Volksverhetzung und sonstigen Beleidigungen,
der gute Herr Zechner war der Ansicht als Staatsanwaltschaft dass das weder beschimpfen noch böswillig verächtlich machen ist und damit von der Meinungsfreiheit gedeckt zu 1.
Dann gab es von Kristin XL ideal bei uns auch öfter schon Erwähnung gefunden hat als Anwältin
eine Beschwerde gegen den Herrn czeschner und zwar in einem Ermittlungsverfahren wegen Volksverhetzung da ging es,
darum dass Demonstranten einer afd-kundgebung in Jena gesungen haben eine U-Bahn eine U-Bahn bauen wir von der jungen Gemeinde bis nach Auschwitz die Junge Gemeinde ist in Jena eine,
ich glaube eine evangelische Kirchengemeinde die sich immer wieder sehr liberal und links engagiert auch eigentlich über die Landesgrenzen hinaus bekannt mit,
glaube hast du denn fahrradkönig weiß gar nicht ob diese Kühe.
Ist das der ach so ja ja.
Das ist ne Sohn der sieht ein bisschen aus wie war Holland.
Stimmt.
Hi ist der König Jana der hat auch schon der hat auch schon auf der Freiheit statt Angst gesprochen und so.
Der angeklagt wurde da Widerstand gegen Polizei geleitet zu haben auf der Demo Hohenweiler.
Ja genau der doch wohl nicht fertig Berichte.
Irgendwie irgendwann.
Genau also von dieser von der Kirchengemeinde bis nach Auschwitz wollten diese AFD Leute eine U-Bahn bauen.
Lot.
Lothar König genau und.
Da von denen Leuten gab es die sie nicht so ein bisschen aus wie wohl ein bisschen länger Rabatt er so eine so ein Karl Marx Bad.
Ja so.
Hat er coole Sau.
Auf der Bad Skala liegt jetzt zwischen Holland.
Genau und seine Tochter ist nämlich die Katharina König die für die Linke im Thüringer Landtag sitzt,
also eine politisch sehr engagierte,
Familie und Gruppe und da ist es natürlich,
für afd-anhänger sinnvoll am besten eine U-Bahn zu bauen um die an die polnische Stadt Auschwitz anzubinden sagte dann auch der,
sagte dann auch der Staatsanwalt der nämlich im Prinzip obwohl es Bilder von den Beschuldigten gab keine Zeugen vernommen hat und den Fall mit einer skurrilen Begründung,
eingestellt hat denn er fand diese Äußerung,
wieder unter dem Blickwinkel der Beleidigung noch unter dem Blickwinkel der Volksverhetzung strafbar Auschwitz sei nämlich eine Metapher ähnlich wie Waterloo.
Ein bagatellisieren oder gar leugnen der Geschehnisse im Vernichtungslager sehe er bei einer solchen Äußerung nicht also man sie,
wes Geistes Kind er ist ein Kommilitone von ihm der mit ihm an der Universität Heidelberg Jura studierte bezeichnete Martin zschächner alt
Spinner der damit angab Sütterlin lesen zu können Wagner Opern pfeift durch die Gänge zog und Kautabak kaute,
wegen seiner rechten Einstellung seit damals schon bei den Professoren angeeckt und alle wussten dass er Rechtsaußen stehen,
mit Staatsmacht ausgestattet ist er eine Gefahr sagt der
komme eben meine Kommilitonen der alte Richter in Baden-Württemberg ist und Richter in Baden-Württemberg sind jetzt auch nicht unbedingt in der Tradition von Lothar König unterwegs wär so stellte sich dann auch raus dass der czeschner auch Spender
Andi AFD ist wenn auch mit geringen Beträgen,
aber die politische Nähe ist hier glaube ich relativ klar zu erkennen insofern habe sich da auch die Theorien dass es sich hier um politisch motiviertes Vorgehen handelte bestätigt und das finde ich ehrlich gesagt,
Sneakers.
Weißt du der Link eierlesen.
Tim jetzt fang du nicht auch noch.
Aber ich war Wasser schon dabei wenn man irgendwie noch eine Oma hatte.
Auch eine Wagner-Oper Pfeifen du kannst das Mais.
Habe ich auch schon mal gemacht.
Das meiste worauf Rechte stolz sind ist jetzt nicht so besonders schwierig außer halt mit einer bestimmten Hautfarbe an bestimmten Ort geboren zu werden das kriegen nur die wenigsten aus eigener Kraft hin.
Kautabak ist jetzt auch nicht ganz normal.
Ja also die Ermittlungen wurden eingestellt der Herr Zechner wurde mit anderen Aufgaben betraut und auch von seiner Funktion als Pressesprecher entbunden weil er sich auch noch öffentlich zu dem Thema äußerte also wirklich.
Kannst du.
Nein ich lese Schriften die gebraucht werden ich kann auch kein Latein weil ich Sprachen spreche die andere auch.
Sütterlin nee kann ich nicht weiß also nee kann ich tatsächlich überhaupt nicht morgen irgendwo gesehen habe ich aber bin bisher gut klar gekommen ohne Sütterlin lesen zu können.
Ja ist auch jetzt nicht so.
Wobei vielleicht wenn man wenn man in in in Thüringen ein Ermittlungsverfahren.
Ist gleich ganz gut.
Schlecht wenn man das in Sütterlin einfach nur mal so als Virtue signaling the.
Deutscher Schrift meine Oma hat noch in hat so geschrieben und deswegen war ich da exponiert.
Ich muss mal gucken für das ist ja so diese etwas.
Deutsche Schriften hat mir das auch also das ist,
eigentlich einfach nur normale Ausgangsschrift für Schreibschrift und Zeit so eins der der Schreibformen die ist so in der Entwicklung des des deutschen lese und schreib Wesens gegeben hat und.
Die sieht alles so kompliziert aus das Kuh ist ein bisschen übertrieben dass er ist irgendwie.
Ja das eh vor allem mit diesen zwei senkrechten Strichen das ist so der der deutlichste Unterschied ne.
Ja dass er sieht wieso SS-Runen aus ne das A ist auch schwer entartet möchte ich sagen.
Aber und das ist das Wichtigste die Zahlen sind auch in Sütterlin Arabisch.
Ist ja erbärmlich.
Da der Zechner oder das Herz der Kamerad Zechner ist auch.
Sie sind ja gar kein richtiger rechter schreiben arabisch.
Sie können ja zählen gut.
So weiter.
Also schön dass wir auch das hinter uns haben und zeigt aber auch tatsächlich wie tief.
Eben auch anziehen an entscheidenden Stellen des der Staatsmacht wir inzwischen unterwandert sind von von politisch fehlgeleiteten irren die.
Polizei und im Gesetz in Justiz und das ist ja das ist in der Tat etwas was zurückgedrängt gehört ja zurückgedrängt wurde nun auch,
der Vorstoß von Julio Sanchez in die Weltöffentlichkeit das könnte jetzt ein bisschen schwieriger werden was ist passiert uns erreichte alle die Kunde das.
Ecuador das Asyl was sie,
Julian Assange in der Botschaft in London mittlerweile seit sieben Jahren gewährt hat nicht weiter zu gewähren breit ist und dementsprechend,
wurde er jetzt von britischen Behörden festgesetzt und das gibt uns die Gelegenheit,
hier mal aufzurollen nicht nur was jetzt gerade passiert ist war vielleicht was auch überhaupt passiert ist weil wir festgestellt haben dass diese ganze Julien Assange Nummer vor 10,
9 Uhr.
10 Jahren ging es im Prinzip los also die des das Licht der Öffentlichkeit in in in breiterer Form erblickte Wikileaks ein nicht beim beim 26 C3
der Vortrag Wikileaks release one point o war das glaube ich also vor jetzt neuneinhalb Jahren,
gab's dann den den Vortrag im Berliner BCC von daniel Domscheit-Berg und Julian Assange wo sie bisherige Aktionen von Wikileaks.
Erzählten da gings dann so um diese Enthüllung zum Bankhaus Julius Bär und aus der Veröffentlichung vom BKA noch relativ kleine Dinge also Julius Bär war glaube ich das erste,
größerer international relevante Dinge von Wikileaks bis dahin war das aber noch jeder stand da noch sodass,
sag mal die Enthüllung im Fokus und weniger über welche Plattform dies genau gekommen war und mit diesem Vortrag damals wurde Wikileaks dann.
Release one point also wir haben das jetzt ein paar mal ausprobiert das hat ganz gut geklappt.
Das wurde auf dem Kongress eigentlich sozusagen als ich das liegt Projekt und
mit wir sind mehr als nur eine Veröffentlichung und wir wollen hier ganz grundsätzliche Dinge anders machen als sie bisher gemacht wurden vorgestellt und.
Auch dass dass dass das philosophische Fundament davon wurde nur mal so ein bisschen auch oder nerve also was für uns ja was haben uns dabei gedacht warum ist das notwendig und so ne wurde in diesem Vortrag so ein bisschen dagesh,
Daniel Schmidt hier ist dieser übrigens damals noch da nämlich deine dummen also ist Daniel Schmidt aufgetreten meine ich,
wenn ich richtig erinnere.
Ich bin auch Daniel Schmidt das war sein Pseudonym und der hat dann fallen in Deutschland auch so die Öffentlichkeitsarbeit übernommen,
war unter anderem V Bundle damals interviewt worden und so weiter da gab's also relativ früher Einblicke in das was diese Gruppe,
so vorhatte naja und dann gings irgendwie alles relativ schnell ich meine was tun,
da im Raum als der Vortrag war.
Ich war glaube ich nicht in dem Raum als der Vortrag war den habe ich nachher als Aufzeichnung geschaut oder oder live im Stream oder so ich erinnere mich wann und wo ich den gesehen habe und also wo aber ich war nicht im Raum.
Ja das war schon irgendwie ich weiß nicht ehrlich also ich muss sagen,
wusste nicht so ganz genau was ich davon halten sollte aber man merkte schon dass du diese generelle Idee schon ein wenig den Nerv der der Zuschauer in dem Moment traf.
Meine was was haben Sie eigentlich angekündigt Silvan halt einfach der Meinung man müsse jetzt hier ein Aktivismus an den Tag legen um halt einfach Informationen zugänglich zu machen für die Öffentlichkeit die,
der Öffentlichkeit bisher so in der Form nicht zugange war und der Gedanke diese Selbstermächtigung auch so der
Hacker die damals ja dann
unterschied dominant war dieses zu glauben man könne mit seinen technischen Fähigkeiten hier viel Gutes bewirken das hat sich da hier glaube ich mir so einen politischen Aktivismus verbunden und ebenso der Saar
Möglichkeit mit einer Plattform so Zahn auf einmal mit eine komplette Gegenöffentlichkeit zu schaffen.
Ich würde sogar noch noch basanov fundamentaler sagen in der Hacker Ethik findet sich ja der Satz private Daten schützen öffentliche Daten nutzen und diese.
Erkenntnis Erwägung und Betrachtung das,
der Staat das Geheimnis für sich beansprucht aber dem Individuum das Geheimnis immer weiter weg nimmt,
während das Umgekehrte richtig ist ja Transparenz nimmt den.
Bösen den mächtigen die Macht Transparenz ist notwendig um die Bösen und die mächtigen zu kontrollieren ja diese gesamte dieses gesamte theoretische Fundament,
das ist ja aber in unserer Community,
schon auch klar und verständlich netv Washington Post hat doch glaube ich jetzt auch seit einigen Jahren das Motto democracy dies in darkness,
und also die Idee zu sagen okay wir brauchen wohl.
Die wir müssen deren Geheimnisse lüften wir müssen sie kontrollieren können.
Das war jetzt auch nicht schwer davon Menschen zu überzeugen in dieser Community und auch an anderen Stellen nicht und ich bin ja auch nach wie vor voll überzeugt dass es natürlich notwendig.
Wenngleich wir inzwischen das natürlich auch mit AntiVir Transparenz gesetzt sie frag den Staat
sie Informationsfreiheitsgesetz solche Sachen natürlich jetzt auch noch mit anderen Möglichkeiten fahren als ihr wie radikal Veröffentlichung im wibukey liegt aber das war einfach das war der Moment und es war auch deswegen erinnere ich mich auch daran
dass ich diese diesen Vortrag im Stream oder eben in der Aufzeichnung gesehen habe weil ich da auch dazu dass du so ok Fakt da ist jetzt gerade was.
Da könnt ihr aber da könnte was passieren.
Da könnte was passieren ja oh ja.
Hat das übrigens damals diese Wikileaks Sache noch da war ich bei in diesem ganzen Zeitraum als das so noch richtig heiß hergehen weil ich bei netzpolitik.org da findet man glaube ich relativ viel Artikel von mir wie ich das damals begleitet habe,
diese ganze Wikileaks denn was passierte.
Dir an die Veröffentlichung von Wikileaks sind eigentlich zu viele an der Zahl um die jetzt einzeln zu würdigen aber das Ding was richtig richtig durch die Decke ging war im Prinzip,
collateral murder ne.
Das war halt das Aufdecken also Wikileaks ist ein Videoaufzeichnungen gekommen die,
Hubschrauber des amerikanischen Militärs während des Einsatzes im letzten Irakkrieg gemacht wurden.
Das ist halt das berühmte Material bei dem,
damals der soldat Bradley Manning heute Chelsea Manning diese Informationen quasi befreit hat aus diesem militärischen Contax Wikileaks hat zugänglich,
Tunichtgut gemacht hat und dann wurde mit einer größeren Gruppe von Leuten dieses Material aufbereitet,
da drauf man sich dann glaube ich vor allem in Island und dann wurde das in einer relativ spektakulären,
Aktion so der Öffentlichkeit bereitgestellt und damit natürlich das Kriegs Gebaren der Amerikaner amtlich an den Pranger stellt wenn man sich das Video mal angeschaut hat das schon ziemlich harter Tobak,
Kurzzusammenfassung ist da fliegt man halt im Hubschrauber rum und ballert so lange auf wie auf alles was sich bewegt bis nichts mehr da ist.
Vor allem auf in dem Fall unbewaffnete Personen zwei Journalisten,
von Reuters na mir noureldin und seid,
ich mag wurden glaube ich dabei getötet und das war irgendwie auch so ein
Thema ja die also es war lange Zeit unklar wie das denn passiert ist dass sie da irgendwie im Irak gestorben sind und üblicherweise wenn ihr zum
kriegsjournalist nicht nach Hause kommen dann gibt's da keine Aufzeichnung von es sei denn du hast eine Bordkamera,
in deinem Helikopter der die Rakete auf den fordert bzw die das mal mit dem Maschinengewehr auf die schießt und.
Dann also auf mich wo es wurde dann noch debattiert dass die Kamera mit dem Teleobjektiv die einer der
eine der Personen trägt
mit einem Gewehr hätte verwechselt werden können oder so ich glaube das war eher eine akademische Diskussion die haben da halt einfach diese Menschen getötet und die Menschen auch keine Gegenwehr geleistet.
So nicht können.
Auf offener Straße einfach ermordet worden und der ist daher eben auch diese dieser Videotitel collateral murder,
an in Anlehnung an collateral damage was hätte mal so die Bezeichnung ist wenn das Militär quasi,
ausversehen bei jemanden aus den eigenen Reihen tötet dann ist das eben ein Kollateralschaden also collateral für auf unserer Seite.
Nee das ist das ist Friendly Fire collateral damage ist generell dieses na ja wir mussten ja hier dieses Kraftwerk zerstören können wir nichts dazu dass da noch 540 wieder Häuser drum herum standen so ne,
und das haben sie halt an der Stelle so ein bisschen gedreht also auf jeden Fall das hat,
ziemlichen Schock bewirkt in der Öffentlichkeit und vor allem halt auch bei den Amerikanern für die Julien Assange ab dann spätestens ganz weit oben auf der wir haben dich nicht mehr lieb Liste stand.
Und dann ging es.
Falls wir da nicht mehr wach bleiben aber ich habe ja mal mit RoboHelp der,
auch in diesem Team der Aufbereitung des Materials dabei war mal ein Podcast gemacht Cre 172 Holland und die Hacker,
das ist eine Sendung die sich um,
noch sehr viel mehr Drehtage auf dem die müssen Sie diese Geburtsstunde der Hackerszene in Holland und Europa also an sich die ganz interessante Sendung aber wir haben dann halt auch ein Teil.
Über diesen Vorfall von Wikileaks und wie er das sah zu dem Zeitpunkt mit drin ist ganz interessant aber.
Mayerhoffer bei dm editing dieses Video ist beteiligt ja das ist glaube ich inzwischen relativ bekannt Werder zu welchem Zeitpunkt,
dran beteiligt war Birgitta jonsdottir Julien Assange RUB congrats sind jetzt so bekanntermaßen mit dem editing und dem Release dieses Videos,
beschäftigt gewesen das war eigentlich auch noch eine,
wenn ich das recht erinnere wenig umstrittene Aktion es war relativ klar dass hier in Kriegsverbrechen dokumentiert wurde,
der Beweis dafür an diese leaking Plattform Wikileaks gegeben worden war die das aufbereitet und veröffentlicht hat und damit ein Kriegsverbrechen der USA,
dokumentiert hat,
natürlich gab es damals auch schon Leute die das ne die dass die sowas dann als Nestbeschmutzer oder sonstiges bezeichnen und quasi Ansichten haben wie ja das,
wo gehobelt wird da fallen Späne aber man indem man,
weiß ja dass Krieg Krieg ist und dann wer sowas macht der hilft dem Feind ja wer unsere Kriegsverbrechen dokumentiert der hilft dem Feind oder so aber das war jetzt.
Nicht kontrovers,
nicht ernsthaft kontrovers unter halbwegs klar denkenden Leuten dass das in Ordnung war was Wikileaks da getan hat
und das ist einer Diskussion bedurfte wenn US-Soldaten Journalisten ermorden
sehr zeitnah kam es dann aber zu der Veröffentlichung der diplomatic,
havells hatten eben noch den also wir gehen nur einige wenige Veröffentlichung von ruhig Helix durch würdig.
Ja aber dass das war jetzt glaube ich schon auch ein bisschen mit das Entscheidende na also Cablegate oder das ja dann schnell genannt das war dann die Veröffentlichung von,
okay bis sozialen der Slang für diplomatische Kommunikation zwischen den Botschaften und USA ca
und hier wurde halt wirklich Insiderinformationen über die Prozesse der amerikanischen
ministration also vor allem das Licht des Außenministeriums der Botschaften in ca klar und da waren auch viele Informationen drin und das war vielleicht auch,
der erste wirkliche Fehler von Wikileaks muss man sagen
insofern als dass sie eben sich entschieden haben diese cables mehr oder weniger ungedeckte zu veröffentlichen.
Ja also okay da muss man da ganz kurz also dieses Ausmaß von Cablegate das ging betraf den Zeitraum von 1966 bis 2 Februar 2010,
Kommunikation zwischen 274 Konsulaten,
und wir und Botschaften zum State Department zum also dem Außenministerium der USA 250.000 dieser Botschaften ja,
insgesamt 261 Millionen Wörtern.
Wurde dann auch von Wikileaks so gesagt die größte Sammlung vertraulicher
Dokumente die überhaupt jemals in die Öffentlichkeit übergeben worden und es gab natürlich Bemühungen da bestimmte Namen raus zu
Niedecken die waren damit befasst aber diese Bemühung können natürlich bei dieser Menge Daten nur fehlerhaft sein,
und weil diese Menge so groß war Wikileaks auch damals sich entschieden mit,
Medien Partnern zusammenzuarbeiten ich glaube das waren so ihr wie der Spiegel auf jeden Fall in Deutschland Limo und in Frankreich elpais in Spanien,
The Guardian natürlich großes Thema und die New York Times mit denen sie gesagt haben hier wir geben euch jetzt den,
Vollzugriff auf diese Daten mach da bitte Stories draus der Spiegel hat dann so eine,
sag mal ungefähr auf dem Niveau von Gala oder bunte irgendwie so,
veröffentlicht hier das sagen die über uns weil dann in diesen diplomatic cables eben auch meine charakterliche Einschätzung über deutsche Politiker gegeben wurde so davor dann das niveau,
dem das Sturmgeschütz der Demokratie dann gearbeitet hat andere Publikationen haben da größerer Skandale rausgeholt und das war vor allem natürlich eine.
Eine Aktion die dermaßen den USA geschadet hat weil quasi deren interne Kommunikation besser kommt irgend eine Gruppe irgendwelche Abgesandten kommentieren Konsulat und du siehst was nachher die Einzelseiten Zusammenfassung des.
Consules ist der dann irgendwie an die USA meldet ja da waren so Pappenheimer von dir geht keine Gefahr aus oder er da muss man mal aufpassen Didi.
Die sind für Umweltschutz oder im solche solche Dinge ne,
das war ein enormer Schaden der den USA da dazu geführt wurde und wenn ich mich recht erinnere erinnere waren die bemüht die zu retten aber es gab eben natürlich Grenzen da drin und es führte auch nachher im weiteren Verlauf noch zu diesem,
Problem zwischen Guardian und Wikileaks das ist nämlich also die veröffentlichte Version der cables waren rejected,
es sind aber nachher aufgrund eines sehr sehr tragischen Verkettung von zustell von von Fehlern auch die Android active cables,
Wikileaks entfleucht kennst du die Story noch.
Ja das Detail hatte ich es nicht am Start.
Ist doch immer so Wikileaks hatte als sie das übergeben haben an den Guardian haben die quasi den gesamten den gesamte das gesamte Set cables als ein verschlüsseltes,
Archiv auf ihren Wikileaks Server gelegt und einen Guardian Journalisten runterladen lassen und dem haben sie das Passwort gegeben zu Entschlüsselung dieser Datei dieser Guardian Journalist,
ich bin mir gerade nicht sicher ob das Luke Harding war oder der andere hat dann ein Buch geschrieben Jahre später über Wikileaks.
Da hat er das Passwort.
Indem er das Passwort,
als Buch Kapitel Titel genommen hat das war irgendwie history of the diplomatic world from nineteen Sixty to the present oder so war das war das Passwort ne und,
nun war Wikileaks zu unterschiedlichen Zeiten mit der Veröffentlichung immer wieder unter die neue laufservice Angriffen um also quasi Überlastung des Servers
und die haben dann irgendwann dazu aufgerufen Wikileaks zum mirror an was auch sehr viele Leute getan haben da hast du also quasi Leute haben ganz viel Wikileaks mirror aufgesetzt und Wikileaks hat einfach sein DNS auf alle diese,
Mirrors round-robin verteilen lassen um so die sind in Hall of service Angriff abzuwehren,
bei Amazon konnten sie sowas hässlich aus das war denn ja auch klar da mussten sie da musste der hat mir noch selber hosten und,
im Rahmen dieser verteilt unsere Server auf breitere stellen und torrent und so weiter wurde eben auch diese Datei verteilt die dann.
Mithilfe dieses Passwort was der Guardian Spacko veröffentlicht hatte.
Hat er es nur als Titel gewählt ohne weiteren Kommentar oder hat er gesagt das sei der Pass.
In dem Buch stand in wiederin Soja und AVI bücherhalter Sinn.
Ja das Passwort war.
Das Passwort war so lang da merkt man der der Julia versteht einfach das längste Passwort ohne und.
So Dinge wie das dann halt so ist ne also.
Wir haben das längste Passwort.
Einer so der einer CD der klassischen OpSec fails und die haben sich dann nachher gegenseitig die Schuld gegeben weil Wikileaks Zeit sagt Zoe man veröffentlicht keine Passwörter niemals und er sagt man löscht Dateien ok.
Das funktioniert natürlich nicht so.
So kam es dann eben zu diesen Zitteraal ganzen cable Season cable Skandal USA aufjedenfall unglaublich verärgert.
Und jetzt fand die Diskussion statt das nämlich diese Veröffentlichung in ihrer Länge und Breite,
indem hier Wikileaks hat das größte League überhaupt dann fingen die Diskussionen an darüber dass es hier ja offenbar nicht mehr um,
Journalismus geht nicht mehr um das spezifische benennen von Missständen.
Wie ist bei collateral murder eben noch der Fall gewesen wäre sondern oben dampen Massen leaking.
Welches unter unter unter Umständen eben auch Folgen hatte für
das jetzt Menschen im Irak oder in Afghanistan die irgendwie mit den USA zusammenarbeiten das da unter Umständen Hinweise gegeben wurden die in den Händen des Feindes nun dafür dazu führen könnten das
Informanten der US-Geheimdienste in den Krisenregionen unter Umständen,
nun endharns sind und Sohn einer wurde also der wurde.
Übersetzer b.
Genau du.
Zur arbeite halt.
Das war natürlich etwas wenn jetzt in den Irak als Übersetzer für die Amis gearbeitet hat hattest du wolltest du nicht unbedingt dass dass das auf LinkedIn steht.
Insofern große Diskussionen damals über.
Die Verantwortungslosigkeit dieser Veröffentlichung das,
ziel dieser Veröffentlichung und ob da jetzt nicht einfach eine Grenze überschritten war die eben sich nicht mehr als wir veröffentlichen Missstände sondern eben wir veröffentlichen hier quasi fünf Jahrzehnte,
diplomatische Kommunikation eines Landes und das natürlich auch klar dass dieses Land egal was da drin steht dir das ziemlich übel nehmen würde.
Und dann,
in diesem Kontext jetzt wird meine Erinnerung auch weil in diesem Kontext fand dann auch diese Ablösung diese diese Loslösung von Daniel von von ricky lippstadt,
die haben also Daniel eigentlich eine Zeit lang glaube ich Julien historisches engster Vertrauter oder einer der engsten Vertrauten löste sich dann im Streit,
von von Julien Assange und Wikileaks ich glaube wenn man das jetzt vorsichtig zusammenfasst hatten sie inhaltliche politische Differenzen aber dann auch im weiteren Ausmaß durchaus persönliche.
Es kam zum ja zum Eklat irgendwann das muss Anfang 20.11 gewesen sein.
Missverstanden September 2010.
Ja okay also September 20.10 schon diese diese Trennung Daniel im weiteren Verlauf Buch veröffentlicht das Buch zur Grundlage wurde zur Grundlage eines Filmes.
Und es führte auch erstmal vorsichtig zu sagen eben zu einer.
Zu einer Diskussion oder zu einer Spaltung in in gewisser Weise auch unter denen den deutschen,
Supportern von Wikileaks in Eben im Prinzip okay hier Schiene Daniel,
Schiene Julien na das war schon bei vielen zu beobachten dass das die da jetzt vor einer vor einer Wahl standen.
Die schwer zu treffen war.
Die schwer zu treffen war Daniel natürlich auch nicht ohne Kritik mit irgendwie ne nachher Buch darüber schreiben und so.
Aber eben auch mit validen Kritikpunkten das war alles in der Community jetzt nicht weil alles insgesamt kein besonders schönes Vorkommnis.
Überhaupt nicht also das hat Ding auf den Clubs irgendwie über Jahre immer wieder ein bisschen mit war schaltet und es war einfach auch schwierig Julian Assange ist ja auch noch ein oder zweimal remote,
auf dem Kongress mit einem Vortrag präsent gewesen auf das hat so eine ganze Menge Konflikte,
geführt mittlerweile ist es Littlest Auftritt von ziemlich lange her.
Ich glaube der war beim 30 C3 wenn ich das jetzt noch.
Irgendwie so in der Größenordnung von 55 Jahren.
Oder die Fernschaltung unter regelmäßigen Aussetzern Lied weil.
Das mit dem Netz auf einmal.
Ein bisschen wackelig wurde aus.
Probleme hatte mit Kabeln die irgendwo ausbüchsen vielen und so also war alles nicht besonders also dieses diese Geschichte ist im Chaos Computer Club Klaus Computerclub.
Eben problematisch aufgrund dieser engen Verbundenheit die der Chaos Computer Club eben auch zu beiden Personen hatte.
Diva Holland Stiftung die Stiftung des Chaos Computer Clubs ist,
eine der Haupt Finanzierungsquellen für Wikileaks gewesen und wahrscheinlich immer noch es ging damals los mit dieser payment Blockade wo,
PayPal MasterCard VISA und andere Zahlung unter nehmen gesagt haben sie können hier überall mit ihrer Karte shoppen außer bei Wikileaks sodass schlagartig die war Holland Stiftung bei der Mann.
Eben per SEPA oder was auch immer Spenden konnte zu einer der wichtigsten Finanzierungsquellen zu Wikileaks wurde.
Was natürlich dann auch entsprechende Probleme für die war Holland Stiftung brachte weil wenn du der Haupt finanziell von Wikileaks bist dann,
hast du halt auch auf einmal mehr Aufmerksamkeit verschiedener staatlicher Institutionen die dann alles mögliche noch mal prüfen wollen was du denn da in deiner Stiftung so veranstaltest und.
Das muss man selber mal sagen die war Holland Stiftung ist ja seiner Zeit zu quasi aus dem Erbe war Holland hervorgegangen ist aber nicht,
direkt sozusagen mit dem CCC verbunden das sind schon zwei vollkommen disjunkte Organisation
stell Dich herzlich kulturell na und man muss auch noch mal sagen
diese Unterstützung war halt nicht eine Unterstützung von Julien Assange soll es war halt eine projektgebundene Unterstützung und es ist bis heute das heißt Gelder werden halt explizit für klar benannte
Auslagen von Projekten Serverbetrieb PC ausgegeben.
Ja das hat die Frau Holland Stiftung auch vor einigen Jahren das haben glaube ich auch hier besprochen.
Noch mal benannt nämlich am 26.07
Tampa 2017 wo sie also Sachen betrifft betrifft Förderung von Wikileaks im Projektbereich Informationsfreiheit wo sie also sagen
ja wir unterstützen nicht Wikileaks sondern wir wir unterstützen Projekte von Wikileaks auf Antrag also Wikileaks
kann dann quasi zu WAF gehen und sagen hier wir brauchen mal soundsoviel für das und das und dann kann die Multivar Holland Stiftung ob das im Rahmen ihrer.
Förderrichtlinie.
Förderrichtlinien und Stiftungszweck und spende Geldspende Gelder und eine Töpfe und so weiter ist und finanziert daneben spezifische Projekte.
An der Stelle war doch auch mal sagen was was oder wer ist eigentlich Wikileaks also klar Julien Assange,
hat das ganze los getreten ist,
bis heute im Prinzip das Symbol und die teilweise halt auch die Ikone für diese Bewegung
tatsächlich dürfte er in den letzten Jahren nicht mehr sehr viel Konkretes beigetragen haben ob seiner Situation eben in der Botschaft also sicherlich wird in irgendeiner Form,
in irgendeiner Form,
MetaDesign ich habe da keinerlei einzige nichtmal Vermutung wahr sind halt andere Leute die an diese Idee glauben und,
eben Quellen erschließen und diese veröffentlichen zu den dann natürlich auch Julian Assange Zugriff hat,
sein persönliches Auftreten muss ich sagen fand ich in zunehmendem Maße verstörend also nicht nur
dieses Etwas dystopische auftreten wie mit seiner tropfenden Wikileaks uns ist es also merkwürdige
Inszenierung noch in zunehmenden Maße Selbstinszenierung seiner Rolle kann man halt schon bisschen so wirklich wieder verschwörungs Papst aus dem internet rüber.
Und auch das dürfte dazu beigetragen haben dass ich diese Spaltung seiner ehemaligen Unterstützer schafft fortgesetzt hat.
Es gab irgendwie um die Rolle von Julian Assange also ein ich habe jeder doch die meisten Leute oder eigentlich sagt jeder von ihm ein sehr starkes Ego und ein schwieriger Charakter.
Ja da würden wir so einige Leute einfallen ins jene die das ganz gut trifft.
Na aber es gibt glaube ich niemanden der das von Julien Assange nicht sagen würde.
Euja.
Und öffentliche haben sehr viel stärkere Begrifflichkeiten der Minimalkonsens ist auf jeden Fall großes Ego schwieriger Charakter,
und die,
das führte damals schon zu Debatten und ich erinnere mich dass er oft zu diskutiert wurde ja es braucht halt so eine Rampensau die das gesamt Ding gesamten die Party den Scheiße Magneten spielt damit die anderen im Hintergrund ihre Arbeit in Ruhe machen können,
nun der Scheiße Magnet hat aufjedenfall gewirkt.
Und ganz schön viel Scheiße angezogen ich denke rückblickend betrachtet kann man schon sagen dass.
Wenn man sich bei einer solchen Organisation für eine öffentliche Person entscheidet dann wäre das wahrscheinlich günstiger gewesen jemanden zu nehmen der weniger Angriffsfläche bietet.
In Äußerungen Sozialverhalten,
und sonstigen wir können es lange noch vor uns herschieben denn auch,
das alles auch 2010 noch.
Ja, da weniger alles auf.
Herbst 2010 nämlich zwei Anzeigen in Schweden wegen Vergewaltigung,
gegen Julien Assange zwei Frauen die,
unterschiedliche aber ähnliche Situation geschildert haben die sie mit ihm erlebt haben die,
ein also die auf jeden Fall unter irgendwie sexuelle Belästigung wenn nicht sogar Vergewaltigungen,
fallen das liegt natürlich dann auch noch mal immer an den unterschiedlichen Formulierungen was genau eine Vergewaltigung darstellt in welchem Land.
Und jetzt hattest du im Prinzip das worauf du die wo man immer drauf warten konnte das dass jemanden der so eine Rolle in der Öffentlichkeit spielt.
Passieren könnte dass er nämlich wegen sagen wir mal,
ganz anderer privater Vergehen oder Unzulänglichkeiten drankommen würde,
natürlich sofort eine Menge an Verschwörungstheorien die sich darum entspannen ja also wie ne die haben den jetzt die,
das ist alles gelogen die Frauen sind von der Formel vom 4er oder so na das ist jetzt irgendwie eine smear campaign und das alles gar nichts dran und die wollen den fertigmachen,
was denke ich mal auch so sicherlich nicht,
ernsthaft aufrechtzuerhalten war aber du hattest jetzt diese sehr unschöne Situation in Schweden also die Ermittlungen und dann irgendwann den europäischen Haftbefehl der von der Staatsanwältin,
angestrengt wurde der dazu führte dass er in Großbritannien eben festgenommen wurde.
Und zwar immer zu der zu dem Thema quasi Befragung durch.
Diese Staatsanwältin und jetzt sagte Julien.
Ich möchte nicht nach Schweden weil ich das Risiko sehe das Schweden.
Diese ist dieses Ermittlungsverfahren da ist ein Witz und Schweden wird mich im im Anschluss daran wenn sie mich einmal in ihren Fingern haben werden sie mich ausliefern an die USA.
Dann stritten sich die die Geister Sachen passen auf das bekommst du auch nicht auf die Idee dass die Schweden dich eher ausliefern an die USA als die Briten die Briten sind,
Metall der five eyes.
Und die haben Falken indirektes Auslieferung.
Haben direktes Auslieferungsabkommen und so.
Davor die Diskussion über eigentlich über Jahre in meinen Augen auch nie so richtig geklärt es wurde auch immer wieder diskutiert ob sie ihn nicht einfach wenn sie ihn doch nur befragen wollen könnten wir nach Ecuador kommen dann sagte Schweden wieder in also nach nach.
Dem kleinen Ecuador bei bei Harrods in London wo die Botschafter in die nehme ich dann Julien also,
flüchtete der hatte er wurde quasi in Großbritannien verhaftet freigelassen und hatte so eine Art Hausarrest.
Und verbrachte den irgendwo auf Sopran ich weiß gar nicht mehr wo das war.
Unser Land wird von einem befreundeten Menschen.
Landsitz eines eines befreundeten Menschen wo er mit einer wie heißt diese Fuß,
mit einer tonischen Fußfessel eben darüber gemacht wurde dass er sich dann nicht
Wer entfernt bin wurde gab's irgendwie das erste Auslieferungsersuchen wurde abgelehnt II dann irgendwie drohte zu kippen da liegt dir dann Schweden Berufung ein und jetzt,
sag was sie am Horizont die Auslieferung nach Schweden und dann.
Begab sich zu Julian ins Auto und fuhr nach London und begab sich in die ecuadorianische Botschaft logbuch-netzpolitik berichtete in der Folge haltet euch fest 29.
Mit dem schönen Titel einmal Asyl und gefleckt.
Immer noch einer der besten Titel.
Und in der Folge 34 haben wir dann auch Julian Assange endlich in Junior Sanchez umgetauft weil er dann nämlich Ecuadorianer wurde wenn ich das richte Erinnerung.
Jetzt hatte.
Ecuador zu dem Zeitpunkt einen Präsidenten mit dem Namen Rafael Correa der so ein linksgerichtete antiimperialistischer
Präsident war der das Asyl aus humanitären Gründen gewährt hat und das auch so ein bisschen durch aus,
innenpolitisch brauchte um oder gebraucht hat,
um zu zeigen hier wir wehren uns gegen die Amerikaner die beginnen ihre Menschenrechtsverletzungen und so und sich damit.
Schon so ein bisschen auf der internationalen Bühne als ich biete den USA die Stirn positionieren konnte.
Oder auch nur auf der nationalen Bühne das kann ich schwer einschätzen ja auf jeden Fall hat er halt so einen Kurs dort gefahren der ihm sehr viel mehr Richtung Kuba Venezuela und den ganzen Dings populistischen Bewegungen hin orientiert war,
und das hat eben also mindestens in den Kram gepasst oder er fand es vielleicht auch alle einfach richtig.
Jetzt wurde 2017.
Dazu sagen dass dieses Asyl in der Botschaft eigentlich eine Verletzungen,
der internationalen Verträge darstellt,
Asyl ist etwas was man nur in dem eigenen Land auf dem eigenen Grund anbieten kann und die Botschaft auch wenn es immer gerne so als exterritorialer Bereich bezeichnet wird,
ist nicht im eigentlichen Sinne das ist jetzt nicht ein Fleck Ecuador in Großbritannien,
sollen das ist halt immernoch Großbritannien nur,
das ist eben diese diplomatische Einigung gibt mit ihr habt ihr dürft euer Hoheitsrecht,
auf diesen Metern nicht ausführen die zeigen wer auch immer ihr habt da nichts zu suchen es sei denn wir machen euch die Tür auf und lassen euch rein trotzalledem ist quasi.
Ein bisschen so wie Kinderzimmer.
Wir sollten jetzt nicht die Kinder dazu fragen wie die das so sehen welche Erfahrung die gemacht haben da Sache ist nur dass das halt eigentlich kein wirkliches,
Dings also so Asyl in der Botschaft gibt eigentlich nicht und ist eigentlich eine Verletzung der Verträge.
Wobei Deutschland das ja auch schon mal gemacht.
Die die Botschaft war jetzt auch zum dauerhaften Aufenthalt gar nicht so gut geeignet,
weil sie relativ klein ist dass es ihr weh doch so ein 2-Zimmer Dingen
60 oder 80 Quadratmeter nichts nichts Nennenswertes obendrüber glaube ich sitzen die Saudis ist doch echt.
Nicht so einfach nicht die beste Wohnlage für Julian Assange und.
Die da ging er jetzt fest und.
Wurde dann eingebürgert und jetzt fahr irgendwie längere Zeit unklar was machen wir da jetzt jetzt hatte der Korea einen alten Weggefährten den lenin Voltaire Moreno,
dessen Eltern eine ein Fable für politische Denker haben ihn dann nach nach Lehnin & Voltaire benannt haben,
früher Einweg Gefährte eben Korea's bei der links und antiimperialistisch 2007 gemeinsam angetreten gewonnen korenova Korea's Vize,
und wurde dann im April 2017 sein Nachfolger.
Und dann das war schon vorher klar dass das so sein würde er verkündete nämlich einen radikalen Bruch mit dem Kurs von Korea.
Als die Wahl da stattgefunden hatte gabs auch in die Ausschreitungen in Quito also Ecuador irgendwie im Bruch,
und Morena Moreno strengt sich erstmal an,
Mit dem Referendum durchzusetzen dass der Vorgänger nicht mehr wiedergewählt werden kann und beendet eben diesen Kurs der,
der Feindschaft zu den USA um wieder Geldgeber aus dem Ausland anzulocken das Problem ist ja wenn du dich als gerade als amerikanisches Land,
mit den gegen die USA stellst dann hast du Probleme im internationalen Handel siehe Venezuela siehe,
Uwe Krüger ein großes gutes Beispiel.
Ja dass sie überhaupt jedes einzelne Land was in irgendeiner Form versucht da Malen an der Wicke anzugehen ist halber door Bob Zentralamerika.
Die haben immer nach kürzester Zeit ernsthafte wirtschaftliche Probleme und.
Gegenbeispiel dann halt sowas wie Costa Rica die da irgendwie voll konform gehen und noch nicht meine Armee.
Genau das sind so da hat sich jetzt hat er sich daneben Moreno entschieden das anders zu machen und damit stand das haben wir auch hier schon öfter besprochen eben die Rolle von Julien Assange da in dieser Botschaft auf einmal am,
Aufkauf ganz anderem auch ganz anderen Füßen.
Es wurde eh schon also mama darf glaube ich nicht vergessen was also der jeweils sieben Jahre in diesem Dings ne,
der klagte nach kürzerer Zeit irgendwie über Einschränkungen im sehen weil er nicht mehr weil seine Augen einfach die ganze Zeit nicht mehr weit gucken können,
ja wenn du irgendwo im Knast bist dann musst du glaube ich weiß ich es nicht neu war noch nicht im Knast dann wirst du ja immer regelmäßig raus gescheucht auf den Hof damit du in Bewegung und frische Luft kriegst,
das ist etwas.
Ein guter Knast ist ja.
Guantanamo ist ne also.
Er konnte da nicht raus weil nthng Platten die gesamte Zeit jemanden vor der Tür stehen der ihn dann natürlich sofort empfangen in Empfang genommen hätte wegen Verstoß gegen die er zunächst einmal wegen Verstoßes gegen die Auflagen,
wir sind der dir da hatte mit er muss sich immer auf
halten also damit war klar sowieso egal wenn wenn egal was wäre so weiter da rauskommt nimm die Briten gefangen weil er gegen seine Bewährungsauflagen verstoßen hat Bewährungsauflage war Dubel du hältst dich hier oft Insa Grafschafter auf und bewegt sich da nicht weg.
Angeblich 10000 Pfund pro Tag überwachungskosten auf 7 Jahre gerechnet sind das 25 Millionen Pfund.
Also das konnten sie sich jetzt vielleicht auch nicht mehr leisten.
14.000 14.000 Pfund haben die da wahrscheinlich auch mehr bezahlt als das Männchen was da vor der Tür standen da fallen mir so IMSI-Catcher ein die man dann.
Na das hört sich ja nicht so einiges dazu auch vielleicht haben sie das einfach in Ecuador anrufen gesagt ja brexit wird zu teuer irgendwie kann ich mir leisten.
Es kam natürlich also man hörte das sei mal jetzt auch die Leinwände.
Wie sagte daniel Domscheit-Berg im Deutschlandfunk im Satz die Julian Assange ist nicht der einfachste Gast.
Und grundsätzlich mein so wenn ihr mal einen Gast Abzuges immer sehr schön aber so nach ein paar Tagen.
Oder 17 Jahren.
Von dir wann hast du stinken.
Dann richten Sie sich auch irgendwann häuslich ein ne und das führte natürlich auch also ist jetzt auch nichts Besonderes füttert zu Spannungen in Ecuador in in der Botschaft die jetzt auch so ein bisschen.
Auch vonseiten Ecuadors,
bist du eskaliert wurden dem wurde das Internet abgestellt weil sie Sachen ey was du hier machst weil Wikileaks hat ja weitergearbeitet siehe
insbesondere auch Clinton Emails
Wikileaks arbeitet da weiter und natürlich Julian Assange immer der sitzt halt da der hatte auf dem Sofa gesessen was soll der sonst machen als seine Arbeit nachgehen.
Außer jetzt noch eine Katze der hat ja eine Katze dann geschenkt bekommen der er Schlipse umgehängt hat aber damit mit der dauert ja auch nur höchstens fünf Minuten wenn machst den Rest des Tages und,
also dann hat er also Wikileaks hat weiter gearbeitet warum auch nicht ne wir verlangen ja auch immer von den Asylanten dass die sich Arbeit suchen,
und das hat Herwig entschuldigen erforscht eben auch gemacht.
Hör doch bestimmt wieder irgendwelchen Briten die Arbeit weggenommen.
Erstmal hat er ja wohl hier für den Polizisten hat der ordentlich Arbeit geschaffen.
Das stimmt es war eine Art amtliche Arbeitsbeschaffungsmaßnahme.
Und dann wurde eben dem wurde ihm ein Protokoll des Zusammenlebens formuliert indem sie Sachen drin standen wie er möge bitte
Ecuador keine diplomatischen Probleme bereiten er soll es jetzt mal hier vom Internet weg sonst drehen sie ihn das ab und und und und und,
julia hat das nicht unterschrieben.
Und hat er so so eskalierte diese Situation in der Botschaft so vor sich hin aber das ist ja immernoch wird jetzt auch in den Medien glaube ich ein bisschen größer beschrieben als es
also das ist bei selbst wenn du da Probleme mit einem deiner Staatsbürger in dieser Botschaft hast heißt es ja nicht weil Saphir keine Ahnung du wehrst dich nicht,
Hotel raus wer der das da spielt glaube ich was ganz anderes ne Rolle nämlich die die die Entscheidung.
Von dem ecuadorianischen Staatspräsidenten Moreno der jetzt offenbar ein ausreichend gutes Angebot der Amerikaner hatte zu sagen,
schmeiß dir mal raus ich habe mir euch.
Man könnte natürlich auch sagen dass sie sich ein bisschen daran gestört hat dass wir gelegt jetzt angefangen hat Korruption
Verdacht zu sehr über die Aktivitäten von Moreno und seinem Umfeld also da gings habe ich umsonst Stau Damen und Zuwendung und so weiter und das wurde dann halt auch alles,
veröffentlicht vielleicht ein bisschen unklug an der Stelle man könnte es auch als,
straightforward bezeichnen so oder so ist es aus dieser aktuellen Perspektive und Nachrichtenlage nahezu unmöglich hier ein klares Bild zu,
zeichnen,
was jetzt genau dazu geführt hat dass dieser TippingPoint ist ob das jetzt eine generelle Ausrichtungen und im peaceman fanden irgendwie Trump ist ob das sozusagen notgedrungen
Ludwig Ludwig war weil Assange nachdem man mit einer Katze fertig war die anderen 80% des Tages darauf verwendet hat da irgendwie alle Systeme auf zu hacken was kolportiert wird von dem wir
keinerlei Ahnung haben.
Ihm wurde unterstellt er habe sich das Internet erhält also es gab auch glaube das war als ich ihn das erste Mal das Internet abgestellt hat haben hat wo ich hier liegt da sofort irgendwie hier wegen Menschenrechtsverletzungen so eine Pressemitteilung gemacht weil sie
ein Journalisten an der Arbeitsstelle Menschen ihre hier ne nicht Gas-Wasser Internet gewähren ja das,
man kann sich vorstellen dass es für ihn jetzt auch nicht mehr so angenehm war in dieser Botschaft und für die botschaftsangestellte auch nicht aber das ist.
Ich glaube das ist alles nur gossip.
Natürlich wenn da irgendwie Menschen auf engstem Raum hängen wenn wir drin erforschen 7 Jahr auf engsten Raum gehst dann gibt's Reibungen ja das daraus aber diplomatische.
Da wir schon Reibungen ohne dass man mit ihr in einem Zimmer wohnt also wird ja dadurch nicht besser.
Ja und also ich denke auf jeden Fall er ist hier Spielball einer einer größeren politischen Bewegung die ihn irgendwie,
die irgendwie auch größer ist als als seine Rolle und da ist jetzt irgendwann offenbar ist der Wert ihn,
da zu behalten eben sehr massiv gesunken im Vergleich zu wir canceln dein Asyl und deine Staatsbürgerschaft und unseren den Briten Bescheid dass du dich abholen können.
Und das ist passiert am Donnerstag am wo also.
Dass das passieren würde König der sich ein paar Tage vorher an.
Und was passiert also am Donnerstagmorgen auf Einladung der Ecuadorianer kommt also dann ein Polizeiteam hält ein Polizei.
Hat Porta vor dem Gebäude die gehen rein und tragen zu den Erforscher fühlen Assange.
Ausgesehen wie die getan haben also das sieht aus als hätten die den so im Sitzen getragene aber die haben eigentlich so im der la quasi auf dem Bauch weil du siehst hinten auf die Beine sie haben so wie wie heißt das wenn du so seine Rakete weißt du so den.
Schiffschaukel Schaukel.
Ja und neben indiene mir jetzt natürlich erstmal gefangen wegen dieser dieses Verstoßes gegen die Bale Auflagen die also die gegen die Bewährungsauflagen die ja ja.
Das ist auch etwas unzweifelhaft.
Er sieht er sieht nicht mehr er sieht wirklich schockierend aus,
ja lange lange Haare langer Bart nicht besonders gepflegt ich höre auch dass er jetzt irgendwie ne.
Jede Form von gesundheitlichen Problemen hatte also einer einerseits gesundheitlich der kommt ja jetzt auch immer der konnte sich da ja ein Arzt hin bestellen aber.
Wer ist Laufband Bader halt nicht und richtig mal ins Krankenhaus gefahren und sich mal untersuchen zu lassen war wahrscheinlich auch nicht drinnen.
Stress ohne Ende also nimmt mental seelischer Stress
hat Michael spontan wirklich erinnert an grausiger Vergleich aber so wie dir der Dennis Saddam Hussein aus dem Erdloch geholt haben ne also sehr verwahrlost hilflos und fertig
er ist jetzt nicht irgendwie.
Das ist jetzt eh Interpretation von drei Sekunden Video oder hat sie noch irgendwelche anderen Quellen.
Ja ich würde also.
Den Eindruck machte es sicherlich ob das jetzt ein korrekter Eindruck ist in dem Moment in dieser Situation keine Ahnung weiß man nicht aber davon ausgehende.
Interessante interessante Aspekte dieses Videos hast du gerade ansprichst als er da rausgeholt wird wer ist da und filmt das Video Russia Today.
Kein anderer da einzige Quelle also irgendwie oder ruptly oder was ist doch alles im wie alles eine.
Ah okay achso habt ja okay das ist das stimmt das ist ja dieser dieser at unter sender ne.
Genauso dieses Narren Film das erhält beim raustragen ein Buch in der Hand wedelt mit einem wedelt mit einem Buch,
also auch recht krasse ob der das jetzt noch mitgenommen hat für die Haft oder ob er damit irgendjemanden was signalisieren möchte keine Ahnung.
Zum buchenbeisl National Security in USA.
Irgendwie sowas wär und.
Dann geht's auf einmal ganz schnell denn den also Schweden diskutiert.
Die Ermittlungen waren ja damals eingestellt worden die Staatsanwältin die Ermittlung damals angestrengt hat ist inzwischen im Ruhestand aber diskutieren ist die Neueröffnung des Ermittlungsverfahren.
Weil das ein Vergehen ist was nicht verjährt dass es gab ein Teil die verjährt sind und es gibt einen Teil der nicht verlieren.
So und jetzt haben die Schweden also auf einmal wieder Interesse.
Und plötzlich ganz ganz plötzlich fährt den USA ein zu den den Zahn ja da halten wir auch noch was ins in Vorbereitung und,
haben ein indightment zur Hand also eine eine Anklageschrift.
Und fahre am district court for the eastern district of Virginia.
United States of America gegen Julien Paul Assange und Hammer seine Anklage wegen Verschwörung.
Zum hacking erzähl mal grob über übersetzt conspiracy to commit Computer intrusion.
Und die Grand Cherry sagt also der Julien Assange habe muss ich mal jemand durchscrollen wo der entscheidende Punkt kommt.
Chelsea Manning damals in der noch als.
Privat in den bei dem US-amerikanischen Militär stellte sicher den diesen Faden der Geschichte haben wir gerade,
eigentlich fast übergangen stellte sich im weiteren Verlauf als die Quelle,
für die diplomatic cables und für das collateral murder video heraus wurde damals verraten von Adri,
einem Hacker und Computer Sicherheitsexperten der vor ungefähr einem Jahr in den USA Selbstmord begangen hat.
Wurde von ihm damals verraten ging in Hawaii in Militär Haft und zwar bis zum Ende der Präsidentschaft von Barack Obama der nämlich als eine seiner letzten Amtshandlungen.
Zimmerling begnadigt hat.
Chelsea Manning begnadigt hatte die sieben Jahre in Militär haftbar,
kein Zuckerschlecken und ich glaube es ist jetzt auch also Barack Obama hat damals ihre gnadenlose Verfolgung auch betrieben.
Ich schätze mal einfach nur dass er sie da begnadigt hat um ihr irgendwie das Leben unter der Präsidentschaft Trumps irgendwie noch.
Spanier.
Jetzt ist gerade wieder in Beugehaft um auszusagen gegenüber einer Grand Cherokee erinnern uns LocoNet riesig berichtete.
Also diese,
diese Geschichte Chelsea Manning Quelle für collateral murder & cables zweifelsfrei geklärt denn sie hat das dem älteren lemmo damals anvertraut MIMO hat das sofort den Sicherheitsbehörden der USA verraten und sie
damit in dieses Militär Verfahren und den militärknast gebracht.
Und jetzt geht es darum dass sie im Bereich März 2010.
Esqua die Kommunikation gab zwischen Julien Assange und Memmingen.
Wo ist der obike darum ging diese Daten zu extrahieren von den Rechnern auf die,
Mining Zugriff hatte in ihrer Rolle als Intelligence Analyst oder was auch immer sie da warum sie dazu gewartet so und jetzt ging es darum,
übrigens in dem indightment,
wird beschrieben sie hätten sich über einen Jabba unterhalten keiner keiner weiß was das für ein was für ein herber hat mir nichts mehr zu tun.
Haben sich über Jabba unterhalten Jabba Chat zwischen Memmingen und Assange,
und Menning später also an die Computer dort vorhandenen Computer unter einem anderen Nutzernamen zu nutzen um so die Identität der Abfragen den Personen zu verschleiern dabei ging es jetzt darum.
Einem also diese Rechner sind Windows-Rechner.
Offenbar hatten die keine,
keine Festplattenverschlüsselung denn was jetzt passiert ist ist ungefähr im März 2010 hat Menning quasi diese Rechner von einem Linux von einer Linux CD geblutet umso,
auf die Festplatte zugreifen zu können ohne den Kontext des dort installierten Betriebssystem ist was es dir wiederum ermöglicht dann Dateien zu lesen die einen nicht privilegierter Nutzer dort nicht lesen kann insbesondere,
die Dateien in denen die Passwörter der anderen Nutzer gehasht gespeichert sind.
Also die Passwörter die zunutze Authentifizierung verwendet werden sind nicht im Klartext gespeichert sondern mit einem bestimmten Algorithmus gehasht dort gespeichert auf diese Datei.
Hat Menning dann so die Anklageschrift mittels des Leitsystems von der CD zugegriffen und die an den Assange gegeben damit er,
sich bemühen kann diese Passwörter zu cracken um dann Menning zu ermöglichen weitere Dateien,
zu holen unter eben einen anderen Benutzernamen,
so und es gibt daneben weil irgendwann 10. März rum fragte erforschen nach mehr Informationen und Menningen,
und er sonst sagte dabei dass er versucht habe dieses Passwort zu cracken und bisher kein Glück hatte.
So das ist alles was die gegen Arthrose in der Hand haben und das ist natürlich tja.
Sehr spannend wie wie bewertest du das.
Das nächste Mal muss man ja mal auch schauen dass wir glaube ich noch nicht richtig erwähnt welche Rolle den Julien Assange ist auch als Person,
im Wahlkampf,
20.16 im präsidial Wahlkampf gespielt hat denn dort gab es ja nun die Veröffentlichung der,
E-Mails der sogenannten Clinton oder DNC emails also es wurde ein Hack vorgenommen von,
irgendjemand beim demokratischen National Committee also dass sozusagen so die eigentliche Parteiführung oder Partei Komitee
im der Demokraten die Saubermacher ihren Kram jetzt nicht sonderlich gut abgesichert hatten,
weiß ich genau wie das gelaufen sein soll aber ich vermute mal Phishing was weiß ich andere Sicherheitslücken.
Beim Podesta was er tatsächlich verschicken.
Allgemein Podesta was verschenkt auf jeden Fall es gab halt ganz offensichtlich Zugriff und der wurde dann eben ausgenutzt und es wurde eben ein größeres Dampf hingelegt und Wikileaks hat diese E-Mails irgendwann,
veröffentlicht und wie jetzt im Rahmen dieser ganzen Mutter Untersuchung und sonstiger Presse Nachforschungen auch offenbar geworden ist.
Hatte die Trump Kampagne schon Ahnung davon dass das kommen würde,
man es gibt ja zahlreiche Aufzeichnungen wo Trump auf offener Bühne
seine Liebe zu Wikileaks Preis und,
ja die die Russen dazu auffordert doch bitte die E-Mails zu
besorgen und wie aus dem Nichts kommen die dann auch und dann gibt's auch so dieses eine ist treffen wo offensichtlich diese Information cane hat irgendwie paar Tage später dann angekündigt er würde ja bald was kommen das kam dann zwar nicht trotzdem fällt das alles in diesem Zeitraum das ist jetzt alles noch nicht komplett aufgeklärt und ist auch noch die Frage ob
wenn überhaupt jetzt dieser Report von Robert Maler
noch mal komplett oder zumindest nur in Teilen zensiert veröffentlicht wird was daraus dann noch für Schlussfolgerung gezogen werden können so oder so ist das Ganze extrem Fischi,
sprich Julian Assange,
hat hier ganz offenbar weil er eben auch fitter über Twitter mit Don junior also Donald Trump Junior in Kontakt stand und diese ganze Veröffentlichung koordiniert hat.
Erheblich in diesem Wahlkampf mit eingegriffen man muss sagen das war dann außer der Punkt wo es mir dann irgendwie auch ein bisschen egal war,
was auch immer für Meriten er sich im Vorfeld
flight angezogen hat aus dieser Gedanke das so mehr oder weniger aus dieser Hackerszene Haare aus hier so ein paar time faschistin Power gebracht wird
dafür die mich dann einfach überhaupt nicht mehr wohl.
Ja sehr gut also wichtig dass das noch mal ansprichst habe ich immer tatsächlich so ein bisschen übersprungen diese Veröffentlichung war.
Wahrscheinlich eine derjenigen die jetzt weniger positive Ergebnisse für die Allgemeinheit herbeigeführt haben.
The diplomat.
Im weiteren Kontext also es hat riesigen Skandal in der in der in der Demokratischen Partei ja aufgewühlt ist zeigt er sich ja Quad sächlich diese im Prinzip Verschwörung innerhalb der Demokraten gegen Bernie Sanders,
das also hohe Parteimitglieder bemüht waren zu verhindern dass seine das,
Präsidentschaftskandidat fehlt in der Kasse strukturell benachteiligten und sich abfällig über Ingo äußert haben.
Es zeigte die gesamten Diskussion um Hillary Clintons E-Mails wiederum
waren dann noch in Stichwort James comey spielt dann noch eine Rolle wo er dann ewig kurz vor der Wahl noch mal sagte ach ja hier bei mir doch irgendwelche Sachen willst müssen uns doch wieder um Hillary Clinton kümmern
die Wahrscheinlichkeit.
Dass das ein Zünglein an der Waage war und vielleicht sogar auch ein entscheidendes Zündern an der Waage was am Ende dazu geführt hat dass Donald Trump die Wahl gewonnen hat ist nicht gering.
Und insofern ist nicht unwahrscheinlich dass diese Veröffentlichung tatsächlich maßgeblich daran beteiligt war das dass wir jetzt im Video Donald Trump da sitzen haben die Perspektive von Wikileaks darauf.
Gabs auch ein Interview zwischen,
hiermit Julien SV Spay intercepted weil Frau sagt naja wir sind ja hier in der leaking Plattform und Journalisten und wenn wir was von denen Republikaner Republikanern bekommen hätten hätten wir es genauso veröffentlicht es ist aber auch klar dass,
Hillary Clinton so eine Art intim Feindin von Joana sajfer,
ich hatte das hier schon mal zitiert der wurde dann gesagt wurde wurde weit genieß wohl korrigiert dass diese Äußerung in der Form von Hillary Clinton nicht getätigt wurde es gab aber immer dieses sich hartnäckig haltende Gerücht Hillary Clinton habe einmal gesagt,
Austrian Airforce angesprochen denn sie war ja unter Barack Obama die Außenministerin.
Nein ich weiß das.
Das heißt diese gesamten diese gesamten Wikileaks Publikationen und so das hat ja quasi auch sie spezifisch ihr mit ihr getroffen und ihr wurde die Behauptung in den Mund gelegt
oder die die Frage in den Mund gelegt can't we just Drone discovery nicht einfach weg Drohnen wie gesagt das ist,
andere Quellen sagen dass das dass sie diese Äußerung nie getätigt hat ist das ein hartnäckiger.
Hartnäckiges Gerücht ist aber Hillary Clinton war auf jeden Fall eine klare Feindinnen von Julian Assange und,
steht eben auch hier die die Überlegung im Raum dass es unter Umständen persönliche Freunde Freude daran hatte Hillary Clinton zu schaden und mit diesem mit dieser,
mit diesem kontaktieren von Roger Stone diesen Typen ohne Hinterkopf der bei den bei den Republikanern,
also ganz gruselige Figur hat kein Hinterkopf dafür aber Tattoo von Richard Nixon auf dem Rücken.
Bist du das benutzt ja auch seine Körpersprache so dieses ausgestreckte Doppel Victory-Zeichen und so weiter als ihn festgenommen haben und.
Ein ganz großer Nixen Fan der Nixen aus Sohn,
ja jetzt unter Freunden Bildes des aufgeklärten und ausgeglichenen politischen Diskurses und der Fairness gar nicht so gut beleumundet er Präsident einer der wenigen,
die vorzeitig abgetreten sind um einem impeachment vor voranzukommen also der der einer von denen die gehen mussten bevor sie gegangen werden.
Und von den wenigen und mit diesem waterston hat bestanden Klicks in Kontakt mit dem,
Donald Trump Junior stand ruhig liegst irgendwie in Kontakt und das war.
Nur noch schwer zu,
schwer zu ertragen für diejenigen die einmal an Wikileaks als eine allgemeine Kraft für das Gute geglaubt haben,
gleichzeitig muss man aber das ist denke ich hier wichtig auch berücksichtigen dass Wikileaks sich immer auf diese Position moment mal wir sind hier ein wir sind eine Whistleblower Plattform und.
Wir hätten ja genauso wenn wir was über Trump oder die Republikaner bekommen hätten wir gleichermaßen veröffentlicht wir können ja nichts dafür was uns die Leute in die Inbox werfen und spezifische immer betont wer bei uns liegt,
der hat einen Anspruch an uns nämlich den Anspruch der Veröffentlichung und wir können hier nicht,
politisch agieren mit dem Material was uns zugesandt wird und sagen das veröffentlichen wir das veröffentlichen wir nicht.
Da muss man sich aber nicht unbedingt mit Donald Trump Junior absprechen darüber.
Ja
Und das ist so der Punkt wo es halt wirklich ein bisschen Fischi und haarig wird und wo ich außer den Eindruck gewonnen habe dass er einfach an der Stelle.
Sich auch von diesem von dieser Idee des Projektes eigentlich gelöst hat und das ist sozusagen eigentlich nur noch um ihn geht den Eindruck macht er eh ganz gerne und.
Ich kann mir ganz gut vorstellen ich weiß es nicht aber in diesem aus dem fortgesetzten Ausnahmezustand in dem der er sich befinden muss,
ist es wahrscheinlich relativ schwierig noch alle Sinne beisammen zu behalten ob ihm das immer gelungen ist.
Man hat so seine Zweifel.
Er sitzt sieben Jahre in in ihrer kleinen Bude mit mit einer Katze und irgendwelchen Leuten die da drin arbeiten mit den du nicht klarkommst und weil deine Quellen sitzen im Militärgefängnis,
also ich glaube der die seelische und emotionale Belastung die der er ausgesetzt war die kannst du wahrscheinlich gar nicht.
Aber nicht nachvollziehen so aber es ist halt auch offensichtlich dass er dann ein paar Abbiegung genommen hat die ich einfach nicht mehr gutheißen kann so das ist einfach.
Ich vermute ist jetzt aber auch nur so eine Vermutung dass er sich vielleicht erhoffte.
Das und Trump in unter Umständen einfach begnadigt.
Nun ich meine unter der unter Clinton und Obama bei ihm ganz klar die haben kein Verständnis keine Gnade mit mir,
und dass er sich irgendwie ausgemalt hat wenn ich jetzt den Trump hier zum Wahlsieg verhelfe,
und Trump wie ein Biala Wikileaks liegt morasha if you hear this und so weiter,
und es wäre jetzt in wie oft unvollkommen irgendwie Trump ist eh alles zuzutrauen also wenn auch zuzutrauen gewesen dass er vielleicht Julian Assange begnadigt.
Und.
Und ist ja ist auch noch.
Weiterhin wobei Tramper inzwischen sagt sowohl kriegst ich weiß überhaupt nicht was es ist ich ich gucke nur fox news Sauna und kann genauso gut sein und.
Irgendwie hat er sich da wohl verzockt.
Und jetzt müssen wir noch mal zurück zu der Frage die ich aber unschuldig an Dich gestellt habe das in Diamond wegen Beihilfe zur Verschwörung zum Cracken eines Passwortes wie blickst du darauf.
Du meinst wie ich das juristisch bewerte oder.
Naja ist also es gibt erstens einmal gibt es gibt darauf verschiedene Blicke einer ist z.b. zu sagen so seriously das ist alles was ihr habt das riecht so ein bisschen nach also es gab die eine eine Lesart war das,
sieht ein bisschen danach aus als würden die USA hier spezifischen das nur benennen.
Was auch in Großbritannien strafbar ist um quasi nur das nachdem nur dafür anzuklagen und nur dafür eine Auslieferung zu bekehren was in Großbritannien problemlos durchgeht.
Und was fallen nicht unbedingt mit Todesstrafe belegt ist.
Genau weil wenn würde wäre es mit Todesstrafe würde Großbritannien nicht ausliefern wäre es in Großbritannien nicht strafbar würde Großbritannien nicht ausliefern und so war eben eine Lesart zu sagen das Ding wurde ist geschrieben,
um eine Auslieferung herbeizuführen.
Eine andere Lesart ist Zusagen naja.
Und das finde ich sehr interessant da werde ich jetzt mal den Kommentar von Thorsten Kleins auf heise.de mal hier unter Verletzung des Leistungsschutzrechte,
vorlesen kosten kleines bekannter,
netzpolitischer Journalismus auch habe ich regelmäßig erwähnt schreibt in einen Kommentar für Heise,
dieses Detail erscheint trivial wie sonst.
Stellt man sich den erfolgreichen Angriff auf die über überbordende geheim Bürokratie der USA vor,
jedes von allen wissen aber nichts von sich preisgeben will aber dieser Vorwurf,
ist vermutlich der der juristisch jede Frage nach der Pressefreiheit beiseite wischen wird,
ich bin Journalist Artikel 5 des Grundgesetzes garantiert mir Pressefreiheit dazu gehört auch der Informantenschutz das heißt ich kann z.b. Dokumente annehmen die aus nicht illegaler Quelle stammen.
Ich kann auch darüber schreiben solange ich sorgfältig arbeite und beispielsweise die Dokumente so weit wie möglich verifiziere und ich muss dem Staat nicht dabei helfen meine Quelle zu finden.
Dieser Quellenschutz hat aber Grenzen wenn ich als Journalist beispielsweise die Abgaswerte von Volkswagen Autos in Erfahrung bringen will darf ich mich natürlich nicht in die internen Volkswagen Server hacken
um die Dokumente zu bekommen ich darf auch keine aktive Hilfe leisten wenn jemand anderes diese Dokumente
hack um sie mir zu übermitteln diese rote Linie gehört zur Pressefreiheit und sie ist nicht wegzudenken,
Journalisten die diese roten Linien überschritten haben.
Gab es in der Vergangenheit leider genug so wurde die britische Presselandschaft kurz vor Oslo aphoristisch Flucht in die,
Londoner Botschaft von Ecuador von einem veritablen Skandal erschüttert
Stephen Murdoch das zum Mörder Konzern gehörende Blatt News of the World hatte im großen vier Prominente und Mitglieder der Königsfamilie Schauspieler
aber auch Verbrechensopfer von Angehörige gefallener Soldaten abgehört indem ist Privatdetektive systematisch Telefon Mailboxen hacken ließ,
es kam zum Prozess das Boulevardblatt wurde eingestellt.
Oder anders gesagt diese Art und Weise der Anklage ist halt auch ganz klug um zu verhindern dass er sich einfach auf Pressefreiheit.
Spezi oder und da sagt er gehört eben auch deutet Thorsten eben hier an.
Hier ist das Ende von wir sind aber Wikileaks eine neutrale Veröffentlichungsplattform weil der spezifisch Menning nach mehr gefragt hat und sogar haking Support geliefert.
Angeboten hat offenbar noch nicht einmal erfolgreich geliefert aber das ist jetzt hier für diese für diese Anklage eben.
Nicht mehr erheblich und ich kann dieser Argumentation von Thorsten auch durchaus folgen.
Ja ich auch also das wird auf jeden Fall nicht einfach andererseits glaube ich ist die Einschätzung auch die,
ist jetzt nicht so dass wir davon damit rechnen können dass er nächste Woche schon auf dem Weg nach New York ist sondern der wird jetzt hier natürlich auch
allen allen rechtlichen Schritten die sich anbieten da sich entsprechend zu neigen und das kann noch Jahre dauern,
bis hier zu irgendeiner Auslieferung kommt egal ob nach Schweden oder nach USA oder sonstwie dazu muss man ja ihr auch noch mal abwarten wie sich das
politisch so entwickelt ja also wenn jetzt wie Jeremy corbyn wider Erwarten innerhalb in einer general election als Hardcore linker irgendwie so in den Korea Modus geht also nicht Nord oder Südkorea sondern der Korea aus
Rafael Correa modus dann.
Ist das auch schon wieder alles ein bisschen anders angemalt auch wenn man vielleicht davon ausgehen kann dass in Großbritannien dann dass du bitte Trennung von Regierung und juristischen Entscheidungen noch ein bisschen anders läuft als vielleicht woanders
Adorno also ich glaube er wird vielleicht jetzt ein bisschen mehr Tageslicht kriegen.
Will also erstmal werden Sie also seine in seine persönlichen direkten Lebensbedingungen werden sich im Zweifelsfall jetzt sehr stark verbessern der kriegt medizinische Hilfe der darf einmal geht einmal am Tag wahrscheinlich raus.
Und.
Aber kein Internet.
Internet wird erstmal schwierig tja und dann stellt sich nicht die andere Frage ist.
Müssen sich die eigentliche Frage ist was zählt wichtiger Internet oder Frischluft.
Ich habe inzwischen braucht er beides nee die die die Frage die Zettel lesen ist auch geil.
Also es hat sich ja hier bisher eigentlich genau das gezeigt was die ganze Zeit sieben Jahre lang hatte das auch jeden Tag wenn ihr jeden gefragt hat er gesagt wenn ich hier rauskomme dann holen die
kommen die Amerikaner sofort mit ihrem in deinen und verlangen die Auslieferung Annemasse meine Güte die Amerikaner nie irgendwas von dir gewollt so.
Du du du willst dich doch nur dem Verfahren wegen Vergewaltigung nicht stellen,
ja Verschwörungstheoretiker ja und jetzt sofort an genauso eingetreten wie es immer gesagt hat und er stellt sich dann natürlich auch noch die Frage wenn das jetzt irgendwie diese.
Ob das,
also bin ich dahinter also ich bin bei der Argumentation von Thorsten bin ich dabei zu sein dafür sollte der ausgeliefert werden in die USA die gerade von einem wahnsinnigen regiert werden,
nein es sei denn Trump begnadigt ihn vorher.
Das könnte schwierig werden durch eine aktuelle Situation.
Tern jedenfalls die also die Reaktion wären das jetzt glaube ich relativ ausführlich mal dargestellt Direktion sind krass du hast echt,
wirklich gerade in der in der US Hacker Szene,
völlig durchgeknallte Reaktion na also was die diesen Artikel gut die haben auch jeden Tag stehen die auf und haben Donald Trump als Präsidenten die haben natürlich,
relativ ausführlichen hasshoff Julian Assange Lärm spezifische.
Theorien um die vergewaltigungs Vorwürfe zum Glück sind wir hier im Logbuch erstmal nur Beobachter.
Eine Auslieferung würde ich auf jeden Fall hoffen dass sie nicht passiert.
Damit ich ihm irgendwann noch mal die Gelegenheit habe ihm ne Ohrfeige zu geben für diese DLC hack.
Die Geschichte ist aber noch nicht zu Ende denn,
es wurde noch ein Wikileaks nahestehender Mitarbeiter in Ecuador festgenommen und zwar Ola Winnie der.
Dort einfach utilix na irgendwie arbeitet,
nichts Genaues weiß man nicht er ist eigentlich Schwede und kann laut Aussage seiner Freunde und seines Kollektivs und Arbeitgebers nicht,
ohne Probleme mit den ecuadorianischen Behörden kommunizieren in der Landessprache also da gibt's noch einen spannenden Fall.
Es stellt sich natürlich auch die Frage so.
Wenn man da jetzt mal ein bisschen in die Verschwörungstheorien sich begeben möchte.
Könnte es ja z.b. sein dass Wikileaks noch mehr uber Ecuador hat,
und es könnte ja ihr wie theoretisch sein dass Wikileaks gesagt hat haben wir wollt ihr ja wirklich mich vor die Tür bei dir wirklich den Assange vor die Tür setzen wir haben ja hier noch folgendes liegen das könnte ja dann
veröffentlicht werden dann könnte die Verschwörungstheorie entwickeln das vielleicht dieses Buch mal ein Signal ist was jetzt veröffentlicht werden soll oder nicht,
ich persönlich halte das nur für.
Also, wenn man die weiter spinnt dann könnte man sich vorstellen dass sie den olabi nie deshalb gefangen halten weil sie sagen alles was Wikileaks jetzt noch veröffentlicht dafür machen einfach den Urlaub bin hier verantwortlich den haben wir nämlich schon.
Und zack geht er in Knast,
halte ich alles für nicht ganz so wahrscheinlich weil was auch immer Wikileaks von Whistleblowern bekommen hat hat Wikileaks ja zum Zweck der Veröffentlichung bekommen,
und nicht zum Sex seinen eigenen persönlichen Geheimdienst dazu führen und Dinge zu,
veröffentlichen oder als Faustpfand oder als erpressungs Möglichkeiten für nehmen um die Verhaftung von Donald er von Donald Trump von Julian Assange zu verhindern.
Wenn sich aber nun zeigt dass Wikileaks ohnehin seit längerer Zeit nicht mehr nur als journalistische Plattform sondern auch als hacking Nachhilfe Organisationen.
Oder sogar Kampagnen unterstützungs Plattform.
Aktiv ist dann weiß man nicht was sie vielleicht tatsächlich noch in der Hand haben das wird auf jeden Fall weiterhin spannend bleiben und wir sind sehr gespannt wie dein nächster Zeit drüber über sich drüber berichten.
So jetzt muss mal langsam mal zum Ende kommen genau.
Kurz zu Wikileaks komme zur Kurzmeldungen tim.
Ja Österreich macht wieder Stress.
Ja das ist keine das ist keine Kurzmeldung der ich hoffe das Thema werden wir insbesondere zusammen mit Thomas hier noch weiter behandeln in Österreich wurde jetzt das Bundesgesetz über Sorgfalt und Verantwortung im Netz,
vorgestellt und das hat eine ganz einfache Idee denn weil Sorgfalt und Verantwortung jetzt eben wieso gering ausgeprägt sind möchte man jetzt sicherstellen dass,
alle Nutzer wäre so gut wie alle Nutzer die sich nehmen welchen Foren äußern namentlich identifizierbar sind,
spezifisch Laute des um der Authentisierung der Authentisierung im sorry,
im der Authentisierung den inneren Registrierungs Profil hat sich jeder Nutzer unter Angabe von Vorname Nachname und Adresse,
Poster zu registrieren dabei hat er einen Nutzernamen festzulegen der im Forum als Bezeichnung für den Verfasser des Postings auch scheint dieser Nutzername muss nicht,
Mit dem bürgerlichen Namen des Nutzers übereinstimmen der Dienstanbieter hat im Wege der Ausgestaltung des Vorgangs
der Registrierung für die Überprüfung der Identität des Nutzers auf Grundlage von Dokumenten Daten oder Informationen
die von einer glaubwürdigen oder unabhängigen Quelle stammen zu sorgen nach durchgeführter Überprüfung sind die für die Überprüfung verwendeten Dokumente und Informationen unverzüglich zu löschen.
Das heißt du registrierst dich in irgendeinem Forum,
bestimmter Größe dazu komme ich noch dann müssen musst du dich denen gegenüber einmal ausweisen du hast sie nennen das ein Vermummungsverbot fürs Internet.
Und natürlich muss dann der Dienstanbieter die technische Möglichkeit gewähren.
Genau erstmal erst wenn du dich Name nicht authentifiziert hast wenn die wissen wer du bist und du hast deine DDT.
Dann darf auch gepostet.
Darfst überhaupt erst posten,
und der Dienstanbieter hat dem Poster bei begründetem Verdacht auf unrichtige oder unrichtig gewordene Registrierungs Angaben zum Nachweis der Richtigkeit der Angaben bin angemessener Frist bei sonstiger Löschung,
Bissregistrierung Profis aufzufordern das heißt also wenn du einen offensichtlich nicht mehr aktuelles oder.
Nicht korrektes Profil dort fürs muss die muss dir die Löschung angedroht werden und die Löschung daneben auch erfolgen sofern du nicht einer Korrektur,
eine Korrektur macht denn der Dienstanbieter das regressions Profil zu löschen a auf Verlangen des Posters B bei Abmeldung des Posters vom online
Inhalte Angebot und C jedenfalls Innenrahmen von routinemäßig periodisch vorgenommen überprüfungs Vorgängen festgestellter Inaktivität von mehr als einem Jahr
die Pflicht gilt für alle Dienste die in Österreich mehr als 100.000 registrierte Nutzer haben oder deren im,
oder deren im Vorjahr in Österreich erzielter Umsatz 500000 € übersteigt das bedeutet.
Alle Youtuber oder Facebook-Nutzer in Österreich werden dieser Pflicht,
unterliegen denn dass der Umsatz von Facebook und YouTube überstreicht überschreitet 500000 € und 100000 registrierte Nutzer haben die auch alle Mal.
Ich könnte natürlich auch irgendwie Angebot treffen die auf österreichische Nutzer Nutzer ausgelegt sind und ihr wo in Deutschland oder sonst wo sind.
Strafen sind irgendwie bis zu 500000 € im Wiederholungsfall bis zu 1000000 Euro wenn du als dieses dieser Registrierungspflicht nicht nach kommst interessanterweise sind die Webshops ausgenommen,
also Webshops und auf die Übermittlung von Waren und Dienstleistungen ausgerichtete Plattform gut sind lieferfähig daran dass du im Web-Shop deine Adresse angeben muss.
Ja du musst dich nicht identifizieren muss jetzt keinen Perso einschicken oder so.
Muss ich nicht identifizieren ja und wer mehr als 50000 € an Presseförderung von der Regierung erhält muss das auch tun und damit haben sie dann so ungefähr alle alle.
Messeförderung von der Regierung.
Ja die ganze Systempresse halt ne also im System und Lügenpresse die ihr mir von der Regierung,
unterstützt wird das heißt damit triffst du alle Mainstream-Medien aber irgendwelche durchgeknallten Fringe Seiten da wo der ganze Hass im Internet sich in der Kommentarspalte,
finde.
Also ist FPÖ Forum sozusagen das bleibt dann noch aus.
Wieso in unzensuriert.at ist irgendwie eine der notorischen French Seiten die Pfeiler genau nicht runter wie das genau gemacht wird bleibt dann überlassen ZBP sms,
schon letztes Jahr haben sie ja bei den SIM-Karten die Anonymität abgeschafft und das Person namens Ding,
Holland epicenter works hat dazu eine PM mit Netmeeting org hat einen Artikel dazu das Gesetz haben wir auch verlinkt und ich gehe davon aus da ich ja relativ bald.
Noch mal mit Thomas spreche in Wien dass wir das Thema noch mal ausführlicher,
besprechen werden das natürlich als ich meine seitlich absoluter Wahnsinn absoluter Wahnsinn.
Das ist schon durch.
Nee das ist noch also noch nicht durch aber du kannst dir vorstellen wie das unter der Regierung mit den mehr als Verhältnissen,
ja jetzt relativ flott passieren wird,
weitere Kurzmeldung die GEMA hat mal wieder eine Charmeoffensive und zwar.
DNS sperren durchgesetzt für Vodafone und 1 & 1 Kunden,
DNS ist wie ihr ja bestimmt bist in der Dienst der Domainnamen in IP-Adressen übersetzt
sodass und hier also wenn ihr die webseite boerse.to von,
Vodafone oder eins und eins Domain nameservers und verlangt dann kriegt ihr nicht,
die richtige Antwort und das betrifft potenziell 25 Millionen Kunden von Handy und Festnetz Beträgen Verträgen die also sowohl mobil als das Zuhause daneben,
boerse.to und ddl-music,
nicht aufrufen können solange sie die Standard DNS Server benutzen die einfache Lösung ist also einen anderen DNS Server zu benutzen was als ich Google oder welchen auch immer,
ihr dort findet an der Fähre also die Möglichkeit die,
weiterhin ungehinderten ein Zugriff auf diese Webseiten zu haben interessant ist wie kommen die jetzt schon wieder auf so eine komische Nummer denn 2015 hatte der BGH gefordert.
Solche das also die die Störerhaftung der Provider die die GEMA nämlich hier geltend macht,
nur dann greift wenn,
die GEMA zumutbare Anstrengungen gegen Betreiber der illegalen und Webseiten unternommen hat also du kannst nicht einfach sagen hier sperrt die und die webseite weil ihr als Zugangs bereitstellen seid,
Stör haftet als Störer sondern du musst quasi nachweisen dass eine 1,
zielgerichtetes Vorgehen gegen die Betreiber nicht funktioniert hat,
und das hat die GEMA dieses Mal getan denn sie hat wohl einen spezialisierten Dienstleister beauftragt eine Art Privatdetektiv der herausfinden wollte wer die Seite betreibt um dort direkt
auf eine Einstellung des Angebotes hinzuwirken deshalb ist erfolglos geblieben und deswegen hat die,
geh mal jetzt hier diese schwer Verfügung erwirkt Vodafone und eins und eins entsprechen dieser Speer Verfügung ungerne müssen es aber tun,
auch das wirklich keine besonders schöne Nachricht wenn das Schule macht.
Wie werden wie ihr seht echt immer weiter ins Darknet zurück getrieben und wir können tatsächlich froh sein dass wir diese Infrastrukturen über die Jahre,
gebaut haben umso auch in Zukunft irgendwo als hidden Services noch ein paar Foren zu haben wir uns nicht vorher mit unserem Personalausweis registrieren müssen und vielleicht auch noch die ein oder andere Webseite zu haben die,
gegen die nicht irgendwo sich irgendjemand findet er da irgendwas gegen hat.
Ja und wann muss man dann ins Internet.
Müssen irgendwie wirklich wird eh Zeit also das mit dem Internet ist jetzt echt langsam durch,
außerdem am Horizont 26.Mai glaube ich ne ja 26.Mai Europawahl.
Jetzt Tim musst du singen Europawahl.
Auferstanden aus Ruinen.
Ich dachte der Zaun Fußballform oder so.
Europawahl.
Europawahl sind das nicht immer zig mal das nicht im Stadion.
Achso Europapokal.
Europawahl.
Europa Puro Papo.
Okay also Europa die Europawahl am 26.Mai da wollen natürlich eine an Parteien rein wäre mir jetzt schon gesagt.
Jetzt auch in Großbritannien wieder.
AFD genau auch in Großbritannien AFD Zettel bitte möglichst bunt markieren und eure Wahl ausführlich begründen auf den.
Für alle anderen reicht ein Kreuz.
Und wenn ihr noch nicht genau wissen wo ihr dieses Kreuz machen möchtet dann könnt ihr jetzt mit dem digitalomat.
Vor allem eine rückwärtsgerichtete Betrachtung machen der digitalomat argumentiert er ist ja so,
versprochen wird im Wahlkampf viel am 26.Mai 2019 wollen deutsche Parteien ins Europaparlament gewählt wenn der digital immer zeigt auf einen Blick die die Parteien in der Vergangenheit tatsächlich abgestimmt haben ja vielleicht eine sehr viel bessere,
Perspektive auf wen man denn sehen möchte nicht was die Partei verspricht in Zukunft zu tun sondern einfach mal zu bewerten was hat die denn in der Vergangenheit getan relativ wenige Fragen,
ich glaube er hat zehn Stück und dann wird eure Übereinstimmung mit den Positionen unterschiedlicher Parteien berechnet und daraus könnt ihr dann entscheiden welche Partei ihr denn,
wählen möchtet wir werden noch weiter weitere,
weiter darüber berichten wie man so wählen kann und wie man so nicht wählen kann heute.
Bremst das ein bisschen achso übrigens noch für die AFD wähle Anne sehr spannend finde ich das Engagement der AFD,
in Venezuela will man gar nicht meinen denn die AFD kämpft ja für ein,
Nachtflugverbot am Flughafen von San Felice das mitbekommen.
Was ich bitte zu Ela.
Ja ja die haben die kämpfen für ein Nachtflugverbot am Sportflughafen makarova in der Stadt Trojaner bei San Felix.
Und das ist nämlich der Flughafen mit dem Kürzel SFX.
Einige wenige behaupten die AFD könnte unter Umständen.
SXF gemeint haben welches der noch nicht existente Flughafen.
Also da mal wirklich die ganz kompetente Front ja also wenn euch wenn euch für den wenn es euch am Sportflughafen von Felix liegt dann bitte auch.
Ausführlicher Begründung bayerkreuz für die AFD.
Es hat überhaupt sehr schwierig zu sein so die genaue Zielsetzung für die Europawahl an der richtigen Stelle in der Karte rein zu stecken die CDU wirbt ja auch irgendwie mit der Frage was sollte im Kiez besser sein
und man würde ja hier für den Kiez abstimmen mehr.
Hast du den Slogan.
Also vor allem weil ja die EU für den Kids verantwortlich ist ne diese Schönheit dann hast du,
Katarina barley kennst den Slogan von Katarina barley Katarina barley kommt zusammen für Europa.
Mit wem Warum was soll das.
Die coxcomb zusammen.
Katarina barley kommt zusammen für Europa ist erst morgen hängt hier also nicht gesehen.
Zusammen mit Europa also.
Für.
Ich weiß es nicht was das soll also das sind wirklich solche Initiativen wieder digitalomat natürlich eine hier da ist das Katharina Palais kommt zusammen für Europa.
Mach das erstmal wieder so ein missratener Imperativ ja.
Ich frage mich haben die ist in der Erdbeere inzwischen alle weggerannt dass sie noch nicht mal eben wieso.
Dann keine! Mehr war nicht mehr rollig ist da.
Doch! Ist da kommt Katarina barley kommt zusammen für Opa weil sie also wirklich inhaltsleere geht es nicht insofern digitalomat da könnt ihr mal schauen in welche Richtung eure Empfehlungen so gehen.
Viel spannender ist ja wahrscheinlich die Europawahl Großbritannien der da jetzt auch stattfinden muss wie du vielleicht mitbekommen hast.
Habe ich heute bekommen gehe ich aber nicht hin.
Ich hätte ja quasi die Wahl also ich hätte hätte die Möglichkeit über da abzustimmen oder hier das.
Oder du machst einen Lorenzo und dafür.
Ja nie hattest also.
Kommt das Buch für den günstigen Flug am 26 und.
Melde mich noch schnell um nein das habe ich jetzt nicht vor ich werde mal absehen wie sich das so entwickelt,
so oder so wollte ich nur sagen
ich habe da gestern noch eine Sendung aufgenommen zum Thema brexit und was denn jetzt eigentlich alles gerade so Phase ist in UKW 003
diskutiere ich ein weiteres Mal mit John USD in Fortschritt beim
brexit noch mal anderthalb Stunde Update zu der ganzen Thematik was in den letzten zwei Monaten so passiert ist und eben auch ein Ausblick auf die Europawahl und was das sozusagen jetzt gerade aus britischer Perspektive bedeutet
unten ja das Öl für die überraschende Detail dabei ist das könnte sich.
Also sie vielleicht auch ein bisschen Hoffnung aber es spricht auch einiges dafür dass das,
sehr proeuropäische Politiker in unser Parlament spülen konnte zusätzlich zu den Vollhonks diese natürlich immer am Start haben,
das finde ich ja ganz gut weil ich glaube die werden auch länger dort arbeiten als Sie vielleicht derzeit noch glauben oder hoffen.
Würden die bei einem brexit am 31.10 dann packen und gehen.
Aber es wird keinen brexit geben.
Zum Leben 5 € reichen wir machen jetzt.
Die Luft ist raus also brexit nimmt jetzt auch in Großbritannien und wie keiner mehr so richtig ernst.
Ja die werden froh sein dass sie scheiße erstmal vom Tisch ist und wenn die wenn dann im im Oktober wieder irgendeine anfängt mit aber brexit Verdi auffangen ey.
Geh mir aus der Sonne also ja wir haben jetzt echt auch mal andere Sachen zu besprechen und dass das ist dass das große Problem das einfach diese ganze Mobilisierung ist einfach weg ist alles dazu in UK W03 Braxton,
aber noch einen Termin die Sendung muss jetzt enden.
Ja mach mal ein Tempel das ist überhaupt nur ein Termin ein Termin die müssen noch kurz hier machen.
Den willst du auch noch passend okay.
Candy digital Politik der Europäischen Union ist ja für uns alle von Interesse und deswegen gibt es am
Dienstag den 16.4 das ist jetzt der Dienstag ein Netz politischen Abend Spezial zur digitalpolitik der Europäischen Union mit,
Susanne Zelt von der CDU Laura Sophie Dornheim von den Grünen,
SPD angefragt Juliane Hüttl von der FDP Konstanze Kriese von der Linken und dr Patrick Breyer von den Piraten,
mal wenn ich jetzt euch halt bei Doktor Patrick bei den Doktor gesagt dann muss ich den auch bei Doktor Laura Sophie Dornheim von den Grünen,
sagen moderiert ist das von john Weitzman vom digitale Gesellschaft e.v.
Diesmal nicht wie sonst in der Sybase sondern in der Alex Halle in der rudolfstr 1 bis 9 Eingang Ecke ehrenbergstraße das ist so U-Bahnhof Warschauer Straße hinten runter,
19 Uhr geht's los Einlass ab 18 Uhr dreißig Uhr 16.04 in der Alex Halle nPA Spezial.
Hab ich auch noch nie gehört Alex Halle.
Nee ist mir auch gerade komplett.
Alex ist dieser freie Sender oder sowas.
Ja ja ich vermute aber diese hatte ist mir unbekannt.
Wieder was gelernt über Berlin und so weiter nun denn ein ein Flugzeug wird kommen und das bringt die mich in die Ferne und weil.
Die Musik läuft noch.
Die Musik läuft nur ich dachte so zum Abschluss könnte man dir vielleicht noch ein bisschen aber mach order.
Kochlöffel.
Ja und weil ich da jetzt hin muss und Boarding Zeit naht so jetzt hier mal einen Ende sitzen hier hat bald wieder von uns und,
bis daheim.
Spart schon mal Geld für für die n MP300.
Hemisphere monetarisieren monetari.
Wie war das Waldbrand bei der subscribe andere Themen als Monetarisierung.
Ja ja ohne Ende.
Ultraschall Release 3.2 Stäbe vorne oder 3.3.
Ja also eine tolle Sachen.
Ich bin sehr gespannt.
Sauer sein aber jetzt ist Schluss bis bald.
Jetzt ist Schluss.